[Musique]
une première soirée est ce qu'ils valent
et des terrasses pleines à craquer place
de la victoire à bordeaux les
établissements font le plein de clients
emmanuel macron aussi à profiter de
cette soirée aux airs de liberté
retrouvée il a dîné à la rotonde hier
soir
[Musique]
maïté minutes d'avis
axa va verser 300 millions d'euros à
15000 restaurateurs le groupe
d'assurances l'annoncé ce matin
cela va permettre aux professionnels
d'éponger une partie de leurs pertes
dues à la crise du coc vide
on était divisée avec les restaurateurs
par un malentendu on a vu que les cours
d'appel en juger dans plusieurs
directions et on veut mettre ça derrière
nous c'est de l'argent qu'on doit on a
l'impression que clément des quelque
chose alors que c'est un dû donc quand
quelqu'un me paye un repas je lui dois
mon repas et c'est pareil pour axa
assurances une premier message c'est ne
faisons pas dire à cet acte imbécile
les violents plus qu'il ne faut lui en
faire dire la société les dans
l'optimisme
le retour à la vie et le retour au
travail c'est peut-être tout autre que
l'auteur de la gifle à emmanuel macron
regrettait à peine son geste et assumer
pleinement sa motivation quand j'ai vu
son regard sympathique et menteur qui
voulait faire de moi un électeur j'étais
rempli de dégoût un acte irréfléchi
selon lui même si ces paroles laisse
entendre une préméditation
quelques jours avant j'avais envisagé de
lancer un oeuf ou une tarte à la crème
avant d'abandonner l'idée
deuxième chose la vraie violence c'est
pas ça et donc il faut pas le perdre de
vue je serait indécent à vous dire ce
message il ne faut pas malgré tout pas
banaliser ce la menotter visage caché
damien tard elle est ce soir incarcéré
il écope de quatre mois de prison ferme
nous sommes devant une société qui est
en train de basculer dans le pré
fascisme et qui est en train de préparer
si vous voulez le lit de l'extrême
droite et ça ça m'inquiète énormément y
compris le débat public les thèmes me
félicite d'une réponse rapide parce que
c'est comme ça qu'on redonne du sens au
travail de nos forces de l'ordre qu'on
redonne du sens à la victime qu'on
redonne du sens aussi à celui ou celle
qui a commis le grave ou le pire parce
qu'il comprend
nous assumons d'être l'opposition
effectivement la plus cohérente et
crédible
je récuse absolument ce que vous
affirmez comme quoi jean luc mélenchon
diffuserait des dettes des thèses
complaints exemple que jean luc
mélenchon à plusieurs reprises a franchi
la ligne rouge et qu'il ne peut pas être
celui qui rassemble la gauche et les
écologistes
donc effectivement aujourd'hui il faut
se poser d'autres questions est allé me
faire d'autres candidatures moi j'en ai
eu une main vous propose la lady anne
hidalgo
moi je suis candidat à la présidence de
la république avec ce slogan le défi des
jours heureux et donc je ne veux pas des
jours violent gentiment s'en aller
joueur violent oui sont devant nous une
séance parlementaire public vire au
drame en bolivie un député du mouvement
vers le socialisme
le parti au pouvoir et un sénateur de
l'opposition du parti de droite créé
moss en sont venus aux mains et monsieur
chenu en particulier il ment sciemment
il sait exactement que ça n'est pas vrai
il n'aimait pas la contradiction vous
êtes news
en vous en prenant année meurent alors
que les projets dont vous parlez nous
répondre mm nouveau fait la loi devant
un tribunal
au coeur de la discorde l'emprisonnement
de jeanine agnès figure de droite et
président par intérim de novembre 2019 à
novembre 2020 pour la gauche sa
nomination était un coup d'état
des accusations que conteste fortement
la droite monsieur bertrand est ce qu'il
est possible de me laisser terminer une
phrase mais pas menacé de poursuites
juridiques monsieur chaunu mabille a
regardé je le regardais en lui disant
une chose je sais pourquoi je vous conte
bas depuis 1990 cinq ans le premier
ministre jean castex et qu'à contacter
il va se placer durant sept jours à l'
isolement sud annonce de matignon même
s'il a été testés négatifs dans la
soirée
[Musique]